the head of the fairy Raiders Fox law
who in reality is a half Thai man who's
in a homosexual relationship with a
black guy is the subcultures definition
of Hitler
[Music]
I guess go through all the effort of
dancing get him show up when we go there
we go there you go there you go look at
him he's a gamer he's that he's willing
to come in and and make it up now for
those of you saying
what's happening let me fill you in this
so our next guest first up you can
follow him on twitter at master zelich's
z e L o X or for Canadians they say Zed
Zed which I've got into a fight with my
I got gotten into a fight with my
professor about that in school as you
should have correct me Zed and I said
ABCD efg hijk LMNOP QRS TUV wxy Z Zed
and the teacher said you're out you're
out about it our next guest is there's a
subculture classified as furries now I
had encountered this you know this at a
Western Michigan flea market at one
point and I had no idea what was going
on so subculture with I guess there a
lot of misconceptions I have to be
honest I don't know exactly what the
furry subculture is most people think
it's a sex thing I've heard it's not
necessarily but our next guest actually
there's there are several different
layers there because he is to the right
of center of most furries and so he's
deal had to deal with some ostracization
there so uh masters masters Alex thank
you for being here sir absolutely thank
you for having me
well I'm glad to have you so now okay
Marley was dead to begin with right
let's set the stage here I have to
acknowledge when I don't know what I
don't know explain to me the free
subculture is a lot of us think it's is
it people who dress up like animals and
go gangbusters no no that's a small
portion but you'll find a small portion
of most of anything in the subculture
actually okay
Fairey essentially is anyone who
identifies as such becomes or ten
integrates into the subculture what a
fairy is is someone who enjoys
characters that have animals with human
characteristics okay also known as
anthropomorphic characters right and if
you enjoy those characters in different
mediums movies books shows all kinds of
things then you can self-identify with
the label of furry and be one okay so
now are
masters Oxford you prefer zelich's quo
that looks is okay zelich's thank you
well we casual are you do dress like
this all the time like do you work like
this are you going to work like this or
is this something you do as a hobby this
is ah okay interesting question okay it
is a hobby for some it's a lifestyle for
others it's a aspect of being for many
okay for me I've been a fairy since I
was 12
the majority of my life I I created to
this this costume myself and I wear it
on occasion but only occasionally okay
so you sure you're not going you're not
going to work you're not going into your
day job dressed as this absolutely not
well I don't know here's what I will
tell you the weirdest thing that I'd
ever see it was afraid of flea market
okay and this was a person dressed up
like a fox hmm but the weirdest part to
me was this person was just going
through a flea and I'd never encountered
this before and not a Jerry knows the
story but he had the Fox outfit and then
he had a button-down and breeches over
the Fox up like it was the Foxes casual
Friday and I was growing yes I didn't so
so this is the Fox in work clothes is
that pretty common because we're several
layers deep into the your guess is as
good as mine at that point human
characteristics its wearing clothing
okay doesn't need to it has fur it would
be absolutely pointless and too hot it
has human characteristics okay so this
is so it seems to be like for a lot of
it this is more of a at least even if
it's a lifestyle this isn't necessarily
you're not pushing legislatively to have
furry bathrooms it's it's it's it's fun
it's it's it's dress-up it's fun some
people feel it's a release for some
people oh yes it's it's a skype ism is
enjoyment it is for many a way to enjoy
and express themselves like comic-con
yes okay got weird to me
but okay there are a lot of adults and
as a result there are adult aspects of
the cub subculture of course you get
these kind of things well you will also
find
within the subculture a far more
significant proportion of GLBT ie etc
individuals yes well that was going to
be my follow-up question what would you
wager percentage-wise people are into
the whole furry thing just for the the
kinky stuff just for the kinky stuff I
would say none okay because you are you
are focusing solely on the kinky you
have to remember there is the the
enjoyment aspect the personality the
enjoyment of animals so there's all of
these other concepts right okay so for a
would you say percentage-wise let me
rephrase percentage-wise of people who
are attracted to the sexual component to
it more than the expression of fun well
what would you say percentage-wise are
people who are out there having fun
dressing up versus people who are
primarily attracted to you know the the
furry sex parties I I can't even pretend
to imagine I could know that number
unfortunately well this is this is this
is how people perceive it obviously and
a big part of it because of the LGBTQA
IP push so I know obviously you don't
you're I don't believe here a part of
that community
you are more how would you describe
yourself conservative libertarian
right-leaning
I am a left-leaning libertarian and I
would describe myself as part of that
group actually oh really okay I
apologize I got it no that's not
entirely and it's fine why do they why I
all the hate why are people so angry
with you I mean I had to do some digging
to make sure that none of the claims
were true on us I see a Star of David
there you know Nazi crazy all right err
this is what they've said to you about
you and I know you've had some backlash
just for expressing different opinions
so if you are a part of that community
and you're left leading libertarian and
you're a furry why don't you get the
Hall Pass in the fairy subculture the
Overton Window is so far left and it was
left to begin with but in the last few
years ever since the election of Trump
it has been pushed further left and
further authoritarian as a result anyone
moderately left centrist libertarian
conservative all of these individuals
are getting targeted and told that
they're Nazis their views are bad they
need to leave the subculture okay so
they want you at what how do they Doc's
a furry do they do they figure I mean do
you all know each other's identities or
is it generally kept from each other in
the community and you only live under
these kind of pseudonyms huh how are
they able to find or have they have they
banned your furry
identity character as a word yes because
the the fairy identity in character is
you it is it is your expression or the
self within the community okay so you
couldn't for but but do some freeze to
have different furry outfits different
furry characters oh yes absolutely there
are many who have multiple open they
flip constantly but you tend to know who
they are so if you were to change let's
say an outfit if you were to build
something you think they would still
know I wouldn't want to sew looks is me
right
well yeah you shouldn't listen if you
shouldn't have to especially I would
think kind of the last fashion if say of
safe space for being a little different
it would be I'm sure you and I don't
like it but a whole lot but I would
think like they should be taking anyone
that anyone they can get
all-encompassing that's it this is
bizarre that's the most bizarre
component of this to me if you can
believe that it's has gotten to an
extreme the last year or so I would say
all kinds of interesting things have
been happening in the subculture the the
cutting back on freedom of speech and
expression that there have been numerous
individuals who've told jokes and then
from the drugs they have had their
panels in their event banned as furry
conventions and they can't present
anymore they can't run things because
they're said an inappropriate joke once
okay
forgive me here but you're dressed and I
don't I don't know what this is oh is it
a wolf sort of cut would you just write
yeah I okay well they don't need to risk
Fabri to give it a single word okay all
right so so then I don't think it's the
kind of guy who's easily finished so let
me put it this way you're dressed in a
hybrid wolf horn costume at a furry
convention with other people some of
whom are having sex dressed in animal
what Oh what could be considered a joke
so offensive that it's ban worthy do you
recall your Anne Frank
drugs video yes yes that would be it not
a high tolerance for Anne for the Anne
Frank genre of humor the furries I if
you went to a furry convention I believe
he would be called a Nazi oh no doubt
yeah the categorization of Nazis is so
extreme that there is an individual Len
Gilbert he's written the book out of the
ruins the main character of this book is
a soldier from our world he's
transported to a furry world and many
antropomorphic creatures around there
the character happens to be a part of
the world war ii german army okay in
this fictional book he is now a nazi
right he's been doxxed harassed his
works been called all kinds of horrible
things because yes like the last furry
castle a scriptwriter for that would be
would be banned ah
potentially I don't know what that think
of just boot okay let's make sure to
clear the air because you'll have people
say you're a Nazi let me let me make
sure
uh you don't hate Jews correct you know
you don't believe anyone is racially
inferior no you don't believe in
nationalized socialism to the great
nation of Germany undermined Fuhrer no
okay so okay listen listen folks I did
my due diligence I'm sure I'd be a
little bit wildered with with what's the
answers let me ask you this too because
I know having done some research and
listen I'm sure you can appreciate that
for me this is going into a dark
internet wormhole some of this stuff I
did find out that there's a no lying
thank you for your candor in alignment
with an toughie and the furries it
almost like you seems kind of with [ __ ]
hats and black lives matter and and and
March 4:15 it's it's this odd
amalgamation and it seems like that's
permeated the furry community as far
political activism am I getting that
right why absolutely you are in fact
it's it's not just activism it is
recruiting and attempting to prove that
they're right and it has gotten to the
point where one of the major very
subculture specific websites broke its
own terms of service to change the code
of conduct instantly without warning to
remove several groups of people and
several people who have been performing
things off sites that they didn't agree
with okay and now and what's in there
banning them because they're both yes
absolutely okay it's primarily two
groups the three Raiders and alt furry
now old furry the name is a joke it's a
parody of the Opera and the fairy
Raiders are a group of fairy individuals
who are friends or as freighters come
from I'm gonna have to call you on that
what is what's the meaning the furry
Raiders it comes from Second Life it was
founded in Second Life and they would
raid particular areas and do some
trollish type drugs oh okay and they're
all Nazis because they wear an armband
with the paw print on it the head of the
furry Raiders Fox Law who in reality is
a half Thai man who's in a homosexual
relationship with a black guy is the
subcultures definition of Hitler I don't
know what to do with that and here's the
thing usually we have some kind of a
call to like I don't think there's much
we can we can do to help you being able
to talk about this at all is assistant
okay you know like free Tommy Robin so
we just come off that was like listen we
don't I don't know the Thai guy I don't
know his gay black lover uh and I don't
know so yes there's nowhere I can direct
people absolutely okay
a good example of you speaking of
anti-fur in the fairy subculture would
again be back to furaffinity that they
have been banning people who have been
speaking out against domestic terrorist
recruiting on-site right because one
thing is true about fairies
they are mostly disenfranchised social
outcasts I would imagine yeah as a
result it's a very palatable area for
this kind of ideology to recruit from
there it sits there in an area trying to
have escapism trying to enjoy themselves
the perfect place for propaganda to take
place I would imagine and and a lot of
people gonna give me flak for this I
would imagine that the the prototypical
furry is someone who was probably a
social outcast like you said probably
very intelligent as opposed to social
outcasts who might join gangs or who
might just turn to drugs it's probably
somebody who's now cast with an overly
active creative mind and so this is an
outlet it's a way to express themselves
where they feel safe so I would imagine
that would be fertile recruiting grounds
because you're looking for people who
are carrot you know a lot of people can
become charismatic in character or in
another and my brother was that way in a
lot of comics he's to work with we're
very very nervous before going on stage
and they had these personas and they
were incredibly intelligent but a lot of
them were very needy you know and I
would imagine that's probably very
similar with a lot of people on a
practical question how do you beat the
summers because it's hot as Satan's butt
crack down here and I don't think you
would see many furries in Texas that's
true what do you do come to Australia we
have incredibly hot summers which I
believe are worse than Texas
occasionally yeah and what you do is in
the large fur suits if you happen to see
them first suits are a very subculture
specific term for the mascot costumes
designed of your character okay you have
a couple of fans and you live with it I
mean I appreciate the explanation but
it's kind of what I would have guessed
first suits meant I mean it's not like
it's not like there was a curveball okay
well alright so there
and they would probably have like a
there's some kind of a fanning mechanism
in there yes yes there's a couple of
computer phones easily in the muscle
area okay all right well listen I
appreciate what listen I would love to
have you back and I listen I first off
legislatively the second furry if furry
start pushing for different bathrooms or
teaching kids about freedom I'm yeah I'm
gonna have some disagreements and I
think you understand that we've got a
same relationship with with Blaire white
but I hate to hear that you're
ostracized from a community just for
having different views certainly is a
more left-leaning libertarian so you are
at masters ELYX
Z elo X and do you educate come back
this has been illuminating for me even
if I don't get it
even if I'm not on board with all of it
I appreciate you helping us out
understanding this usually this is the
point where I would tell you to
subscribe or hit the notification bell
up there because subscriptions don't
mean a whole lot on YouTube but if
you've been signed up now at lotto with
credit comm slash mug club for all the
daily content to support us there's
probably there's not a pitch I can make
here that'll work so let me just tell
you this I have a cat in my basement
right now if you don't subscribe it
louder with CARICOM slash mug club to
support this content I am going to kill
him if you don't subscribe this cat in
my basement will die